[Música]
[Aplausos]
amaya ya supuso a
ustedes se preguntarán qué es la cultura
wayú cómo está organizada y si están si
todos se encuentran en el departamento
de la guajira hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes acerca de mi cultura
la cultura wayúu
se encuentra en la alta media y sur de
la guajira en la zona rural
estamos organizados por territorio cada
territorio tiene un clan un clan es un
apellido el apellido de una familia que
se rige a través de la línea materna es
decir la mujer es quien forja la vida y
asegura una generación adicional a esto
otra de las características dentro del
territorio es que tienen un gobierno una
justicia propia y un control social para
que este esta sociedad pueda funcionar
de la manera más organizada posible
cuando les hablaba del gobierno es que
se rige también a través del tío materno
es el aula entonces de esta manera
cuando les hablo del control social es
que tanto la mujer wayú como el hombre
why you tenemos roles el rol del hombre
why you
el pastoreo algunos nacen para hacer
palabrero puig y puch que son mediadores
y conciliadores para que pueda haber
armonía y paz dentro de los territorios
además
también nacen hombres que son
autoridades ancestrales que es el tío
materno el que nos representa en ante
todas las instancias ante los demás
clanes ante los demás territorios y es
la máxima autoridad dentro de un
territorio
yo soy de la alta guajira y cuando nací
mi mamá fue atendida por dos parteras
que son mis abuelas yo nací en mi
territorio no nací en un hospital con
decirles que pasado muchos años pasaron
años quizás 34 años que yo no tenía un
registro civil tanto así que mis mis
padres se olvidaron hasta en qué año
nací pero pude obtener mi registro civil
un día se encontraba mi mamá conversando
con mi tío materno la autoridad
ancestral de mi territorio la persona
que en lo ve decimos y respetamos ese
día conversaba y observaba a mi mamá
triste cabizbaja pero ella luego se me
acerca y me comenta mariah
tu tío habla de una necesidad de
interactuar con los alijos para nosotros
los alijos son las personas que no hacen
parte de nuestra cultura o que tienen
una cultura distinta a la nuestra es
decir ustedes son algunas cuando mi mamá
me comentaba de que tenía que irme de mi
territorio con tan apenas 8 años yo no
entendía tenía temor y le preguntaba
porque tenía que ser yo porque he sido
elegida por mi tío para ir y abandonar
todo mi mundo donde apenas estaba
creciendo desempeñando todos mis roles
como como mujer como niña pero tuve que
partir tuve que partir porque tenía que
cumplir con esa obediencia y con esa
necesidad que tenía mi tío agarre mis
cosas con mi tío
mi manta mi mochila mis guaireñas y tuve
que irme para el sur de la guajira que
ya es donde desean mis tíos que donde
estaban los alijos los alumnos que
podían ser mis padrinos con la garantía
de que me pudieran brindar una mejor
protección cuando llegue a ese mundo
diferente al mío enfrentar nuevas cosas
a la que estaba totalmente
me encontraba como qué va a pasar con mi
vida que lo que me voy a enfrentar pero
tuve que hacerlo al principio me dio muy
duro cuando mi madrina me hablaba
yo lo obedecía pero realmente no sabía
que me decía porque pues no sabía hablar
la lengua de los alumnos la lengua de
ustedes no lo sabía pero tuve que
aprender sufrí llore muchas veces cuando
en las mañanas despertaba en el suelo
porque mi madrina me entrego un cuarto
con una cama
y yo en las mañanas amanece en el suelo
porque no sabía dormir en una cama pues
estaba acostumbrada a dormir un
chinchorro
aparte de esto tenía que sobrevivir
aprende aprendí tres palabras
tengo sed tengo hambre y tengo sueño
porque es que en la casa de mi madrina
también se acostaba muy tarde once de la
noche doce de la noche donde yo siempre
acostaba acostumbraba con mi familia en
mi territorio que apenas ocultaba el sol
todos nos acostábamos a dormir porque a
las cuatro de la mañana iniciaba nuestra
actividad y escuchar nuestra abuela
contar sus historias pero pude superar
todas estas dificultades pude salir
adelante pude aprender la lengua de los
alijos y estaba feliz porque había
logrado algo bueno que muchos de mis de
mi familia no lo tenían pero pasado 15
años regrese a mi tío por mí
veo llorar a mi madrina diciéndome maría
no te vayas tú aquí tienes mejor calidad
de vida pero estaba mi tío sentado
esperando que yo tomara mis cosas para
partir
tuve que decirle a mi madrina lo siento
pero yo debo obedecer ha llegado mi tío
y debo partir con él
cuando llegué a mi territorio
encontré que había una gran fiesta
estaba toda mi familia unida
y mi tío me presento delante de todos
y les dijo aquí les traigo a mi sobrina
de nuestra heredera ella va a ser la
líder de nosotros porque cuando muchos
territorios tienen beneficios nosotros
no lo tenemos pero como ya ella habla el
idioma español
ella puede gestionar recursos ahora para
que para que podamos obtener los mismos
beneficios que reciben los demás los
demás territorios yo les decía claro que
si te digo como no si para eso fue que
usted me me mandó muy lejos para poder
entender y poder interactuar claro que
sí puedo pero cuando me daba la vuelta
con tan apenas 15 años
yo me asusté tenía temor porque pues
cómo iba a gestionar recursos cómo iba a
ser para poder hacer un proyecto pero
pude entender cuál era mi misión en el
momento cuando apenas tenía ocho años
pude entender por qué tenía que haber
partido en esa edad
luego aparte de eso aparte de que fui es
nombrada como líder de mi territorio y
de mi familia encontré que mis hermanas
no estudiaban mis hermanos estaban tenía
una tiene a 14 la otra tenía 13 años yo
le preguntaba porque ustedes no estudian
porque que nosotros tenemos otras cosas
más importantes que hacer tenemos las
actividades de la comunidad y yo le dije
pero vamos a hacer algo vamos a yo voy a
hacer su docente
y después de eso fueron matriculadas en
un colegio ni siquiera ser un primer o
segundo tercero sino que hice en un
cuarto y ese mismo año se graduaron y
hoy día son en no educadoras que están
aportando su conocimiento a la
generación de mi territorio
aparte de eso
mi tío se me acercó y me dijo ya estás
ya tienes edad para casarte maría ya
debes casarte porque mi tío pensaba que
con ya solo tener y poder relacionarme
con osasuna ya no importaba más nada no
importaba seguir estudiando pero yo lo
que no me imaginé es que todo fuera tan
rápido al día siguiente llegaron carros
caravanas y llega un señor alto yo le
ponía por ahí como 40 años yo me
encontraba tejiendo una mochila con mi
tía el señor se baja y le coloca un gran
chinchorro y en ese tiempo me empieza a
hacer me empieza a picar el ojo yo
también le picaba el ojo porque en ese
tiempo pues era una una niña una joven y
después le sacaba la lengua porque yo no
entendía por qué él me sonreía tanto mi
tía me dice pero porque te ríes tienes
que portarse bien porque se va a ser tu
futuro marido yo salí corriendo buscando
la protección de mi mamá
cuando llego donde mi mamá y le digo
mamá
me voy a casar
y yo no quiero porque tengo muchos
sueños quiero seguir estudiando y además
quiero ser esa buena representación de
ustedes mi mamá pudo llegar porque uno
de los roles también de la mujer wayúu
aparte de ser de inspirar en su mochila
de buscar agua no sé a cuántos
kilómetros 510 kilómetros este también
este ser una consejera miti miti o pudo
entender y escuchar a mi mamá y logró
que ese día no me casara
pero al otro día
un primo fue atropellado por un carro y
fue por un alijo no se me acerco mi tío
y me dijo sobrina yo necesito que usted
se siente conmigo a dialogar y a
negociar porque mi sobrino debe ser
compensado y yo con con lobo el respeto
y el valor que le tenía mi tío
yo tuve que decirle tío ese no es mi rol
yo soy una mujer
con todo el respeto como voy a sentarme
en una enramada donde van a ver
palabreros y donde van a estar sentado
muchas autoridades
y me comentaba pero quien le ha dicho
usted que usted va a ocupar mi rol lo
que pasa es que tú tienes un poder muy
importante y es que tú sabes comunicarte
con lo salir una y esta vez no me toca
arreglar con un guayo sino con una lija
ese día en la asamblea en la negociación
yo era la única mujer que estaba sentada
en esa enramada una enramada es el lugar
donde nosotros hacemos dialogamos y
recibimos nuestras visitas cuando me
encontraba sentada
resulta que el alijo no trajo su
palabrero wayúu
y me ha dicho señorita usted está como
qué hace ocupando este lugar o acaso se
le olvidó cuál es su tarea debería estar
en la cocina haciendo café o trayendo
nos la comida
mi tío le dijo lo que pasa es que yo no
vengo a dialogar con guayo sino con una
ligera y yo la necesito a ella porque
ella sí puede comunicarse con él y ese
día pudimos ganar la compensación y
lograr que se pudiera dar el
reconocimiento por los daños causados
pero mis sueños no llegaban hasta allí
al culminar mi bachillerato yo me senté
nuevamente con mi tío y le comenté mi
sueño y seguir estudiando quiero
estudiar en un colegio muy grande más
grande que donde estudie en la
universidad de la guajira
pero como vamos a hacer si nuestros
animales no van a alcanzar para para
darte un estudio en una universidad tan
grande
yo le comentaba admitido lo que pasa es
que mi mamá mis primas mis tías pueden
tejer la mochila y con eso puedo
estudiar y así fue como logré en mi
carrera ser una trabajadora social
que cuando regresé a mi territorio fue
una gran fiesta porque en ese momento
era la única profesional de la familia
del clan que pillo
pero pasado tiempo después metió
nuevamente me dijo sobrina pero yo creo
que ella sí es hora de que se case ahí
pude tener el valor y decirle tío con
todo el respeto
yo debo retribuir la a mis tías todo lo
que hicieron para que yo pudiera
estudiar
mi tío pudo entender y fue cuando empecé
a hacer a entregar mi trabajo mi
conocimiento
aún a ips trabajando con proyectos de
mujeres embarazadas wayú quienes le
temen a tener un control prenatal y a
tener un parto en un hospital pero a
través de este diálogo pude por lo menos
lograr que pudieran estar en control
prenatal pero eso no era lo que yo
realmente deseaba y que mi sueño llegar
hasta allí tenía otras metas
y fue que entré a trabajar en una
fundación y en esa fundación
podía sentarme a hablar no solamente con
mujeres embarazadas sino con hombres
wayúu con mujeres con jóvenes con niños
a que ellos construyeran su proyecto de
acuerdo a sus necesidades y así fue que
pude trabajar y así fue que pudieron
pude ver cómo construían su proyecto
pero yo me ponía a pensar de que así era
tan difícil y tan complejo poder lograr
una gestión y que lo que se necesitaba
era que pudiera tener un contacto
directo donde estuvieran o donde
estuviera una empresa que realmente
pudiera donar esos recursos directamente
y no a través de un intermediario
pero pensé muchas cosas porque resulta
que la guajira y una empresa muy grande
en la que muchos guajiro y muchos guayo
quisieran trabajar pero así también hay
muchos guajiros y muchos wayú que no
quisieran entrar a trabajar en esa gran
empresa
pero a pesar de todo eso yo me yo me
auto cuestionaba que pasara sera
traición para los territorios o será una
oportunidad para que pueda gestionar
recursos que den grandes impactos para
los territorios pero me arriesgue y pude
entrar a trabajar en esa gran empresa
y pude analizar y ver las cosas de qué
son dos mundos diferentes pero que a
través del poder de la palabra la
comunicación y la interacción se puede
lograr grandes proyectos se puede lograr
que territorios y entre wayúu y noah
wyle puedan lograr tener una interacción
una comunicación que pueda que pueda
traspasar fronteras pueda traspasar
límites y barreras para poder lograr
grandes gestiones para los territorios
wayúu
pero por si ustedes se preguntaban ajá
pero si tanta insistencia del tío ella
pudo lograr todas sus metas qué pasó con
el tío será que el tío si logro que ella
pudiera casarse este año yo le presenté
mi novio a mi tío cuando se lo presente
me decía
y digo este es mi novio y me decía del
clan uriana claro que sí como me alegra
tanto que sea wayú como yo y él es ya
sitio y yo me casé y estoy en la tarea
no solamente de buscar proyectos y
gestionar por hoy y proyectos para los
territorios wayú sino en la tarea de
poder lograr esa generación que tanto
anhela mi tío muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]